o vendedor diz ser um boa noite muito
fraco godot ronan vai eu tenho um
objetivo e um desafio começa pelo
desafio primeiro ficar quieto aqui
segundo os admiro todos e o objetivo é
ao longo do tempo que eu conseguir
respeitar aqui inspirados em 2014
civ criar entre aspas de chittagong
agora quer consegue que no facebook ou
no integral então e desde essa altura
que o uso das tags sublegenda dele o be
legendary não é mais do que traduzido
para o português ser lendário e
secundário é uma coisa muito simples e
ao mesmo tempo hoje em dia - fácil que
nós vivermos de acordo com o que os
nossos valores é nós vivermos de acordo
com o que a nossa essência é nós
vivermos de acordo com o que o que
verdadeiramente o nosso eu lido
diariamente com os gestores com atletas
com suas com todos nós e que o mais
encontro é dificuldade que as pessoas
têm em seu fluxo então era isso que hoje
vinha e que fazer vai inspirar visser
foi isso e ser lendário é isso mesmo nós
respeitarmos a vida é nós respeitarmos a
nossa responsabilidade da felicidade
durante alguns minutos em 46 anos e cria
durante alguns minutos fazer algo
facilmente fácil que contarão suas
histórias da minha vida desses 46 anos
pai em três ou quatro minutos
portanto também vai ser mais um desafio
ao cheta anos fui abusada sexualmente
minha experiência e dor foi minha
primeira queda dos novos seis anos sofri
é que o que nós falamos hoje naquela
altura esse termo não existia bullying
em escolas muito bullying
dos 9 aos 16 anos o gordo o vison o
canoas o vidrinho e era que eu quero é
ser usado
aos 19 anos prevê um dos meus amigos de
infância possui sírio e companhia
durante muito tempo por isso porque
achei que estava ausente em estado longe
deu durante o último ano
vive um relacionamento antes disso vive
num lar onde é violência doméstica era
algo semanal por vezes até diário vive
um relacionamento de dez anos funcional
vive um outro relacionamento de dez anos
abusivo réplica é um pouco daquilo que
eu vivi até porque nós aprendemos a amar
com quem nós vimos em casa com nossa
família os nossos pais a história do
nosso pai abusar vai aumentar disse koji
comentou fisicamente ou a nossa mãe
também
nós achamos que isso é amor achamos que
isso é normal que faz parte
então nós é e pensamos não respeitar
aqui o que é a felicidade de não
respeitar aquilo que a vida começamos a
não respeitar aqui o que acima de tudo a
nossa integridade enquanto ser humano
não foi tudo mal
tive uma vida corporativa com bastante
sucesso e um bom cargo era dono de uma
empresa fazer aquilo que eu queria
quando cria três cartões de crédito e
dourados com limite de crédito
substancial uma carrinha não se pode ser
que marcas mas devo dizer bmw com que
teme quem é que gosta do que tempo e
usava andava rápido e dava cenário
viajava muito primeira classe
restaurante bons hotéis gols toda a
gente queria ter minha vida
- eu pensei por que não era feliz que
tenha um sonho
nessa mesma idade bush tanto tinha um
sonho que era ser médico
a médica nessa aula
parabéns e obrigado porque o processo
fazem de alimento e eu queria ser médico
assim muito porque queria ajudar os
outros eo meu pai tinha opções para pra
mim como qualquer pai que ama o seu
filho cria o melhor o que ela achava que
era o melhor o melhor pra eu era o
livrará nossa empresa e foi o que eu fiz
até que em 2005 alguém novo com 88 anos
poucas horas antes de ter deixado este
plano e de ter ido com o ano fez uma
questão um homem que nunca tinha ouvido
falar que eu tinha desenvolvimento
humano desenvolvimento pessoal nem
anthony robbins não sabia ler não sabe
escrever recebido valores de vida
respeitava é vida respeitava o ser
humano ou fez uma questão muito simples
um gol é minha vida foi filho estava a
viver a vida que tu queres viver e viver
a vida que os outros querem dúvidas foi
um murro no estômago literalmente
momento lembramos aqui é um sonho de que
o menino com 70 anos e o sonho de ser
médico que ajudar os outros
e foi aí que minha mudança teve início
nos anos mais tarde ouvi falar desse
senhor tony robinho sequer um motivador
um carro que fazia e vende pra mim as
pessoas que se viram desses eventos e
num desses eventos lá atrás eu disse um
dia eu vou estar aqui neste palco um dia
eu vou fazer isso e alguns anos depois
tornar no primeiro português no primeiro
round de língua portuguesa a fazer parte
daquilo que é considerada a melhor
equipa do mundo e mais tarde o trailer
entretanto fui pai em 2009 fui pai deles
nesse relacionamento que eu tive abusivo
no show que o que melhor me aconteceu à
minha filha leonor 2009
em junho de 2003 foi confrontado com o
pior desafio que o ser humano pode ser
confrontado de uma doença do estômago
aliás do motor de estômago normal
foi diagnosticada a minha filha leonor
com 4 de maio um cancro nos rins muito
humor bilateral 16 cêntimos no rim
direito
oito centímetros no rim esquerdo mais de
trinta taste nos dois pulmões
assim tenho uma sobrinha dela na sexta
feira o flu ia chegar à escola com duas
tranças e na segunda-feira em um
diagnóstico mas sentença no hospital de
cascais duas a quatro semanas de vida se
o psique mil não funcionasse que me
funcionou durante 15 meses e no dia 3 de
setembro 2014
a minha filha no nó partiu e deixou este
plano e hoje eu sou pai de um anjo da
onu provavelmente alguns de vocês aqui
nesta sala tomaram conhecimento dela
vieram antes que ela é ela quem era o
jorge coutinho queria aqui está ela
inspirou surge no país inteiro não só
pelo país inteiro mas por aquilo que eu
faço como tendo ligações pelo mundo
inteiro inspirou pessoas pelo mundo
inteiro em cima tudo porque ela
respeitava a vida ela respeitava a
felicidade
independentemente do que ela estaria é
viver o objetivo que ela tinha era é
apenas um serviço apenas um ser fui
aprender muitas coisas com o nono
principal foi talvez desta forma o
evento mais atitude igual resultado
nunca tenha a ver com aquilo que nós
vivemos ainda pouco falava com o com
alguém sobre um sonho que essa pessoa
tem a primeira coisa que ela dizia sim
só que eu queria fazer isso mas a
história é desculpa
todos nós procuramos uma desculpa para
não ser injusto isso todos nós
procuramos desculpas para não sermos
aquilo que nós verdadeiramente somos
para não vivermos aqui o que é o
respeito pela vida pela cidade
por isso que nós não tínhamos nós
mexemos com dois objetivos e nonô viveu
esse objetivo é marcar e ser feliz
não é ser amado amar e ser fui a maré
incondicional é unilateral e primeira
pessoa que nós devemos amar e respeitar
a nós próprios
só assim conseguimos amar
então nada daquilo que nós contamos nada
daquelas histórias nós encontramos para
dizer que o tempo estava de fazer isso
eu tenho estava ter e qui eu até gostava
de ser kill esqueçam isso é apenas uma
história e essa mesma história que vos
impede de vocês terem serem ao fazerem
que vocês mais gostariam
não é dado não é dinheiro não é tempo
não é nada disso porque está a jogar
neste mundo que com muito menos recursos
de tempo de idade de dinheiro que está a
fazer isso que vocês gostariam de fazer
então não é o evento é a atitude que
está a impossibilitar outras coisas que
eu aprendi qual connor é que
independentemente daquilo que acontece
na vida é nossa suicidava qualidade da
nossa vida não está ligada com isso está
ligada com o que o faz com isso eu tenho
todas as razões da experiência e todas
eu costumo dizer que tenho um piti de em
dor não em sofrimento porque todos os
dias como não sofrer é uma escolha de
alex faixa
eu tenho todas as razões para não ser
nada daquilo que são hoje um sonho
realizado e feliz como nunca fui oito
dias no doi a falta da minha filha e
todos os dias eu escolhi ser suíço aliás
em que eu consigo
aliás em que o prendo então há duas
coisas que nós precisamos de entender é
que nós queremos carro fique melhor na
nossa vida ter mais tempo mais dinheiro
mais sucesso uma melhor relação aquilo
que for mais saúde
nós temos que ficar melhor vamos começar
a fazer melhores escolhas
nós cremos calmo na nossa vida a mudança
começa em nós temos que usar as escolhas
que nós fazemos diariamente e é quando
nós entendemos isso que sabemos o que é
o poder pessoal e ver que uma escolha
tem o poder que uma decisão tem como diz
não é amigo e mentor tony robbins e nos
momentos de decisão que o nosso estilo é
traçado e quando nós decidimos phone que
ouvia elle traz mais algumas pessoas
eram três mil e quinhentas e eu estava
bem lá atrás tinha vivido quatro dias de
uma intensidade de uma viagem interna
profunda onde eu tinha entendido uma
série de coisas não tinha respondido a
questões que nem eu sabia que eles
tinham sobre mim e foi que houve ali
atrás sem saber como a 11 anos que disse
um dia eu vou estar lá em cima
curioso há dois anos atrás eu decidi que
queria estar num telex e este ano estou
que o universo conspira quando nós
decidimos é preciso que nós façamos algo
então o poder pessoal
o maior poder cruzeiro mantém o poder de
decisão
minha pergunta para você o que você
costuma viajar decidida por medo de
qualquer coisa se você já tiver assim os
mesmos fizessem essa decisão que mudaria
com a vossa vida e não só na vossa vida
mas devido às duas que vocês amam se
tomassem essa decisão que estão a
avaliar o que mudaria na vida dessas
pessoas que você ama que seria diferente
provavelmente iriam viviam ter desafios
até porque a vida não ostenta
passadeiras vermelhas vida coloca nos
mostrava com buracos com ela com muros à
nossa frente o que evita que ela é quem
decide se quem está lá em cima mostrando
que mesmo após essa decisão passei por
tudo que passou ileso
passei por tudo tudo valeu a pena por
como pedro acho que foi peso disso nós o
nosso primeiro orador o nome diz não é o
destino em jornada e foi a jornada
entrou no homem que o urso e acima tudo
a dor que eu vivi foi o do porto criou
músculo
foi a dor que desenvolveu a minha
experiência minha persistência o meu
querer ser feliz
então como descrita frank ouvido o foco
foi um dos criadouros
a viagem foi o criador de um tipo
específico de psicologia e foi também um
museu que teve em auschwitz e prendeu a
família em auschwitz e o que identificou
em auschwitz foi que as pessoas não riam
apenas pelas condições que presencial
elas morreram quando previam uma direção
quanto previa um sentido quando deixavam
de acreditar que poderia haver uma vida
é cíclica
elas pediam a fé e fé que não é nada
espiritual é fed vai correr bem vai ver
algo melhor lá na frente
isso não acaba aqui e quando suas
províncias
essa crença essa fé essa visão era
quando elas começavam a morrer
quantos nós às vezes não vemos uma vez
nos vemos diariamente porque temos aviar
uma decisão
estamos com medo de decidir é maior que
nós temos levado iva da vida minha filha
viveu todos os dias e queria viver muito
mais então o cruzeiro é da decisão o
cruzeiro da escolha e se há algo que
vocês hoje hoeven desta minha palestra e
se vão ser feliz
escolha um ser flu isso é uma decisão
diária e deixamos de ser um segredo é
muito mais fácil de ser influi ser
difícil diz
os livros dizem que a ajuda é fácil não
é fácil dá trabalho é como ir ao ginásio
é conter um corpo de ginásio a trabalho
é preciso compromisso disciplina
consistência fui cidade é a mesma coisa
precisamos decidir diariamente
precisamos mesmo querer ser feliz e nos
lembrarmos que influísse dado faz parte
da felicidade
não tem mal nenhum em ter dias horríveis
não tem mal nenhum eu ter desinfluentes
o que tem mal eu achar que eu não
deveria ter um dia infeliz o que tem mal
eu não sentir vem com um dia infeliz
porque é perfeitamente normal um dia
infeliz é como a morte a morte é
perfeitamente normal é morta é o oposto
da vida ea única certeza que o ciro
mantém nós procuramos segurança
procuramos certeza a única certeza todos
nós temos é que não vamos ficar
eternamente todos nós iremos partir um
dos mais chegados mais tarde uns
prematuros uns de doença ou acidente e
morte natural nos todos iremos deixar
este mundo então já que o iremos deixar
que deixamos uma marca que está a ser
lendário que esperemos as outras pessoas
independentemente daquilo que nos
acontecem independentemente dos desafios
que nós vivemos
estamos a viver e vamos viver ainda que
os vivemos de sorriso nos lábios que
olhemos para a vida como a maior dádiva
porque as pessoas mais felizes nós somos
tem tudo
os mais foliões que agradecem tudo
aquilo que tem e eu vou desafiar embora
já esteja quase a reinventar o meu tempo
mas vamos desafiar a fazerem é fazermos
aqui um exercício rápido nem isso senhor
não ok então durante um minuto apenas ou
menos - feche os olhos e vos guiar numa
mini micro detenção
eu vou te dizer que fecha os olhos e ao
mesmo tempo que fecha os olhos coloque a
vossa mão direita a vossa mão esquerda
sobre o vosso coração e sintam esse
coração que bate e sintomas gratos por
isso coração bater e ao mesmo tempo
estou a sentir essa gratidão de se
desconheçam combate colhem para a vossa
vida corda em si um momento lá atrás que
era há muito tempo você já não se
cruzavam e sintomas graves sintomas
gratidão de terem vivido esse momento e
agora procura em outro momento
atrás porque se ontem potência semana
passada mas passado um ano dez anos e
sinto um instrumento agora sinto a
gratidão disse meta precisará abundância
sintomas graves por terem vivido esse
momento e agora voltem agora em peças
que é diferente é quando nós perdemos
quando desligamos destes aparelhos que
nós hoje em dia temos que nos dão tanto
podemos nos conectamos com que o que é
verdadeiramente importante que somos nós
e com os momentos felizes que já vivemos
e é isso que eu os desafio porque eu não
quero que vocês vivam o inferno e o
inferno e no último dia aqui na terra
vocês encontrarem frente a frente o
pessoal vocês poderiam ter sido
e por culpa de não se virem por culpa do
mesmo não foram então o meu convite
sejam lendárias ontem já era tarde sejam
lendários hoje sejam lendários até o
final da vossa vida
deixem uma marca de felicidade e
abundância
neste planeta terra obrigado boa noite
[Aplausos]
[Música]